If you're doing any type of
troubleshooting in Windows, then you've
probably used Task Manager before. This
is a realtime view of some of the most
important statistics that will help you
understand how the Windows operating
system may be performing. There are a
number of ways to start Task Manager.
One of the easiest is to press Ctrl
Altdelete and select the option for task
manager. You could also right mouse
click in the taskbar of Windows and
select the option for task manager or
use my favorite shortcut which is
control shift escape and task manager
will instantly appear. Once you start
task manager, you'll find a number of
different tabs across the top that will
choose different statistics in different
parts of the Windows operating system.
We'll start with the services tab. This
can of course be also accessed from the
control panel, but this will show you
all of the services running on your
system all from the task manager front
end. This is a very easy way to access
this list of services. And from here, we
can start, stop, or restart any of the
services running in our Windows system.
The services tab is usually at the end
of the list of task manager tabs. And
you can see all of the services running
on this computer are listed. You can
right mouse click on any of these
services to start, stop, or restart the
service. And you can launch the services
applet, which provides you with even
more
options. When you first log into
Windows, you'll notice a lot of
different applications will
automatically start during that boot
process. You can manage this list of
applications from the startup tab of
Task Manager. When you're
troubleshooting a problem during
startup, you may want to disable one or
all of these different startup
applications to see if you can resolve
this particular issue. Then you might
want to turn them on one by one or in
different groups, restart your system,
and see if you're able to pinpoint where
the problem might be occurring. And that
way, you're able to disable that
particular application during the
startup process. Here's the startup tab
in Task Manager on my computer. There
aren't a lot of applications listed
here, but I can right mouse click on any
of them to enable or disable that
application during
startup. If you want to view all of the
running applications on your Windows
computer right now, you can see them all
inside of your task manager under the
processes tab. From here, you have a
single view of all of the applications
that are currently running on the
Windows desktop and you can view the
background processes that are currently
in use. The default view is to see the
CPU usage, memory, disk, network, GPU,
and other metrics. But you can also
rearrange these columns, sort by
different information in these columns.
And if you right mouse click, you can
add additional metrics to this view.
This is a great summary of everything
that's running on your system. And being
able to sort these different columns
allows you to easily pinpoint what
application might be using the most
amount of memory or the one that's using
the most amount of network
resources. When you first start the
troubleshooting process, you may want to
get an idea of just how much CPU
utilization is currently in use, or you
might want to see how much memory is
being utilized. You can see all of these
from the performance tab in a graphical
format that shows you information over
the last 60 seconds. This historical
view allows you to get a feel for how
different applications may be using the
hardware resources of your computer. And
from here, you can start troubleshooting
if your problem might be associated with
CPU usage or if your problem is related
to memory or network. Depending on the
configuration of your computer, you
might have different metrics listed
along the left side. On my computer, I
can see CPU utilization, memory usage,
disk usage, network configurations, and
on my particular system, I can also see
my graphical processing
unit. And of course, Windows is a
multi-user operating system. Not only
can multiple people log in to your local
computer, you can have people connecting
across the network to different
resources that are on your local
computer. So although you may be the
only one sitting at your desk, there may
be tens or hundreds of people that are
accessing resources on your computer
across the network. You'll be able to
see all of these users who are connected
through the users tab in task manager.
You'll be able to see exactly who's
connected and then you'll be able to see
what applications or what resources they
may be accessing. And since this is your
computer, you also have control over who
may access. And from this view of task
manager, you can choose to disconnect a
user if you'd like to remove their
access from the system.